okay welcome to the computational
complexity session of
idcs 2021 uh daniel please
hi you can hear me right
thank you all for coming this talk is on
total functions in the polynomial
hierarchy
this is joint work with my advisor
christos at columbia bobby kleinberg at
cornell and oliver courtney colombia
so here is an overview of this talk at a
very high level
uh in this talk we're interested in
function problems not decision problems
so in particular we're interested in fnp
and not np
so what is fnp for example think of the
relation mapping
satisfiable formulas to their satisfying
assignments
um but of course not every formula
participates in this relation because
there are formulas without satisfying
assignments so this motivates the
definition of tfnp
which are those problems in fmp that are
total so for every input there's going
to be an output
and recall from the complexity that an
np generalizes to a polynomial hierarchy
of classes sigma i and pi
in our work we generalize tfnp to an
analogous hierarchy of total function
classes
of t of sigma i and we identify natural
problems and subclasses in this
hierarchy
so briefly a relation rxy is total
if for every x there's a y such that xy
is in the relation
and tf and p are those relations that
are in f and p and are total
so in this slide i'm trying to explain
to you why we care about
t and p subclasses and you may have seen
such subclasses before ppp
ppa ppad etc so to show that a decision
problem is hard or to motivate that it's
hard we show that it's empty complete as
evidence
so to show a total search problem is
hard maybe we would show that it's tfmp
complete
and we would like this but we strongly
believe there aren't tfnp complete
problems
but tfnp does have many canonical
canonical and natural problems where we
know a solution is guaranteed
so this problem is total but we don't
know how to compute one in polynomial
time
because uh the reason we know it's total
is some sort of non-constructive
combinatorial argument or principle
so what we can do is then define
subclasses by reduction to these
canonical problems
and what that ends up doing is grouping
total search problems
by this non-constructive combinatorial
principle that's in its totality proof
so that's what all these classes are
doing and then you can establish
evidence of hardness for some new total
search problem by showing it's complete
for one of those subclasses
that's sort of the agenda so here's an
example
um consider the following combinatorial
principle given a mapping with fewer
outputs than there are inputs
there must be a collision by the
pigeonhole principle so here's a
concrete corresponding computational
problem
given the circuit from n bits to n bits
either find a pre-image
of the zero string or if there isn't any
find a collision
this is in tfnp and we define the
subclass ppp as those relations that are
polytime reducible to pigeonhole
but now consider this combinatorial
argument the empty pigeonhole principle
given a mapping with more outputs than
there are inputs there exists an empty
pigeon hole
and the corresponding problem empty
given the circuit mapping two to the n
minus one inputs to two to the n outputs
and the way we do this is just by
ignoring the zero string as an input
find a y such that there's no x that
maps to y at very first glance this
looks somewhat similar to the pigeonhole
problem you might think it's in ppp
maybe it's ppp complete
but when you think about it you'll see
this is highly unlikely i mean maybe p
equals np but
to verify a y you'd have to check that
every single pigeon hole doesn't map to
this y
there's some sort of all quantifier at
play so this motivates the definition of
tf sigma 2
which are those total search problems
that are in functional sigma 2
the more specifically their total and
the verifying machine m is such that for
x y in the relation
for all z of polynomial length m x y z
accepts
and analogously you can define a whole
hierarchy of classes t of sigma i
exactly as how you'd expect so this
empty problem
is in tf sigma 2. and
just how we define the subclass ppp we
can define a subclass p
epp polynomial empty pigeonhole
principle as those total relations which
are polytime reducible to empty
so pep is some subset of tf sigma 2
and you should think of pep as those
search problems where totality is
guaranteed by the union bound because
the union bound is really a restatement
of this empty pigeonhole principle
what does the union bounce say it says
if the total number of
inputs isn't enough to cover some output
space then there must exist an element
in the output speed of
output space outside of the range um of
whatever mapping you have so
it's the same thing um and
incidentally we actually know that we
proved that fnp is
a subset of pep which we don't think is
the case for tfnp so this suggests that
maybe these are
different um so we identify multiple
natural problems in tf sigma 2 and in
fact in pep in the paper but
i only have time to show one of them to
you so i'll show you the coolest one i
think which is complexity
so one of the goals of complexity theory
is to find a boolean function on n
variables with super polynomial circuits
and from an early proof by shannon which
uses the union bound interestingly
we know that almost all function all
boolean functions require large circuits
of course we don't know of a natural one
um
so this motivates a total search problem
find functions that require large
circuits
so for this given a bit string bit
string x of length m
we'll think of x as encoding a function
on log n bits
and then we define an x oracle circuit
simply as a circuit which has an
x gate this gate has log m fan and
computes the function
x so the problem complexity is as
follows
given x of length n find another
function with
log n inputs that is not computed by any
x oracle circuit
with small enough size that by shannon's
union bound proof we know that many of
these functions exist
and this problem is in pep now
there's something interesting about this
problem if you recall empty pigeonhole
problem you just have to have one more
output that input and look for that
output
but complexity actually doubles the
output space at least
there are many unmapped two functions so
this motivates the definition at apep
which is
find at least find an empty pigeonhole
given a circuit that at least doubles
its input space
and i don't have time to define it to
you but another problem in apep is delta
rigid matrix completion which has to do
with finding
rigid completions of a partially filled
n matrix over some finite field
so both of these are in apap and we show
in our paper and the proof isn't hard
that apep is actually in functional np
poly basically
and this matters because we don't think
that this is the case for
uh pep for instance so this might be
some proper subclass of pep
and so natural open problems or whether
complexity or this rigid matrix
completion problem are apep complete
good now let's go one level higher in
the hierarchy let's think about tf sigma
3.
so let's recall what this means the
verifying machine m accepts x y
um if for all alpha for all a exists b
such that the machine accepts okay so a
question is are there natural problems
at this level of a total hierarchy and
i'll remind you
that in the decisional hierarchy the
higher you go up the harder it is to
find that
natural problems but sigma 3 is actually
one of the levels where
sort of one of the last levels where you
have very natural problems for instance
you have the decisional vc dimension
problem is complete for sigma 3. and
analogously
the shattering problem which has to do
with finding large chattered sets
is in tf signal three and the shattering
problem can be thought of as
finding certificates for the vc
dimension
um so very quickly a family of sets f
shatters another set s if for every
subset of
s every subset t you can realize that
subset by taking some set in f and
taking the intersection with s
and the source shell alum which is a
fundamental result finite set theory and
classical learning theory
gives a lower bound uh for the size of a
shattered set
so this suggests a natural search
problem given the circuit which
implicitly represents a family of finite
sets
and a d that satisfies the source shell
i'm not find an s that's shattered by f
with at least this size and it's easy to
show that this is in tf sigma 3.
you check that for all subsets there
exists a set etc
but in fact we've proven our paper and
this is a bit harder to show that
shattering lives in ppp which is the
subclass of the first level of the
hierarchy tfnp
with a sigma-2 oracle so here's a
summary
of this quick talk at a in one slide so
this is what was known before here tfnp
we generalize this to a hierarchy of
total function classes tf sigma-2 and so
on
in tf sigma 2 we have the natural empty
problem which gives rise to pep
and other natural problems like complex
complexity which live in apep
those which at least double the output
space and t of sigma 3 we identify the
shattering problem which lives in an
oracleized version
of a subclass and tfnp and of course you
know for at every level you have
oracle-wise versions of every subset in
tfnp
but the point is we found a natural
problem in ppp with a sigma-2 oracle
in the long talk i show you more
problems this is what you'll see in the
long talk
and we have even more there are more
natural problems and more results in the
paper
um a lot of interest of time will stop
here but these are some open problems
i've mentioned them in this talk as well
i also have a poem which is on the next
slide i don't know what you want to do
very nice yeah so so let's let's keep
the poems for the uh
uh poetry panel at the end of the
session and uh
ishai if you can uh show your site
daniel i think you have to unshare your
slide so you should i can share his
slides
uh okay so i think i think you can go
ahead and start
okay thank you so i would like to tell
you about the complexity of finding fair
independences in cycles
suppose that you are given a cycle graph
g and the partition v1 up to vm
of its vertex set we are interested in
an independent set of the cycle g
that includes roughly half of the
vertices of every part
v i of the given partition more
precisely
we say that an independent set s of the
cycle g
fairly represents the partition if for
every i
from 1 to m the number of vertices of s
that belong to v
i is at least half times the size of e i
minus one as example consider this cycle
on 15 vertices
and suppose that the yellow vertices are
those of the first set v1
the red vertices are those of the second
set v2
and so on every color corresponds to a
set vi
in the given partition and notice that
the highlighted vertices form an
independent set in the cycle
that further represents the partition
for example we have here
five red vertices and our independent
set includes two of them just as
required
in a work of ronnie alone berger
chudnovsky kotler
level and then it was shown that for
every cycle and for every partition of
its vertex set
there exists an independent set that
fairly represents the partition
in a later work of alicia and munir it
was shown that if the number of vertices
and the number m of parts of the
partition have the same purity
the not only that there exists an
independent set that fairly represents
the partition
but there are even two disjoint such
independent sets
that together cover all vertices but one
from each vi
looking again at our example you can see
that there is another independent set
that fairly represents the partition
and together with the previous one they
miss only one vertex from each column
it's interesting to mention that
although the statements of these results
are purely combinatorial
their proofs are based on tools from
topology the first application of
topology and combinatorics
was obtained in 1979 by lovas who proved
that the chromatic number of the knesset
graph with parameters n
and k is n minus two k plus two
where the vertex set of this graph
includes all the k
subsets of the set of integers from one
to n and two such
sets are adjacent in the graph if they
are disjoint
lovas used the birth equivalent theorem
from algebra topology
to precisely determine the chromatic
number of this graph
and this result was extended and
generalized in various ways
one such extension is the one of scriver
who considered
a subwoofer of the knesset graph induced
by the collection
of all the case subsets of the integers
from 1 to n
with no two consecutive integers modulu
m
he proved that this algorithm has the
same chromatic number and this subgraph
is commonly referred to as describable
graph
it is denoted here by s of n and k
the proof of are only at all for the
existence of an independent set that
fairly represents
any given partition of the vertex set of
a cycle is based on the chromatic number
of scribal graphs
since these proofs are based on tools
from topology it is perhaps not
surprising that they are not
constructive
in the sense that they do not supply an
efficient algorithm with polynomial
running time
that given a cycle and the partition of
each vertex set
finds an independent set that fairly
represents the partition
understanding the complexity of such
problems is the main motivation for this
folk
so before describing the results let me
briefly mention a few related complexity
classes
the class tfnp was defined in 1991 by
megiddo and puppet dimitrio
is the class of all the total search
problems those problems for which every
input is guaranteed to have a solution
where the solutions can be verified in
polynomial running
time in 1994 papa dimitri initiated the
study
of total search problems in view of the
mathematical argument that lies at the
existence of their solutions
he defined several complexity classes
each of which corresponds to a certain
mathematical argument one such class is
ppa
polynomial parity argument defined as
the class of all the problems that can
be efficiently reduced to the leaf
problem
in which we're given as input a circuit
that represents an undirected graph with
maximum degree 2
and we are given a vertex of degree 1
and the goal is to find another vertex
of degree 1.
another class defined in this way is
ppad
which is a subclass of ppa that can be
viewed as the analog of ppa for directed
graphs
so it is defined with respect to a
canonical problem known as
end of line and over the years it was
shown that
ppib perfectly captures the complexity
of several search problems of
interest this includes for example the
search problem associated with spanish
lemma
and the one associated with the nash
equilibrium theorem and so on all of
these problems are ppad complete
for ppa however until recently there
were no
known ppa complete natural problems
whereby natural i mean that their
definitions
don't involve circuits and turing
machines but the situation was changed
following recent results of
philosophicals and goldberg
who proved that several classical
problems are ppa complete
and now we are ready to state the
results so we start by introducing the
fair independent set in cycle problem
in which we are given as input a cycle
and the partition of its vertex set
and the goal is to find an independent
set of the cycle that fairly represents
the partition
we show that this problem is ppa
complete
we also consider the first splitting
cycle problem
where we are interested in finding two
disjoint independent sets that fairly
represent the partition
and together cover all vertices but one
from each vi
in fact we consider here an approximate
version of the problem with parameter
epsilon
where the two independent sets are
required to cover at least
half minus epsilon fraction of the
vertices of
every part v i for the exact version of
the problem where
epsilon is zero we showed that the
problem is ppa complete
but we also show that the problem is
unlikely to be solvable in polynomial
time
even for some positive constant epsilon
because for such an epsilon the problem
is shown to be ppa be how
we finally consider this quiver problem
that corresponds to coloring subscriber
graphs
so here the input is a boolean circuit
that represents a coloring of the
squared graph
s of n and k using n minus 2k
plus 1 columns which is smaller by one
than the chromatic number of this graph
so the goal is to find the monochromatic
edge and this problem is also shown to
be
ppa complete i would like to end the
talk with one open question
so in this work we proved the ppa
completeness of the fair independence
set in cycle problem
and it would be interesting to
understand the complexity of this
problem
restricted to instances in which the
vertex set of the cycle
is partitioned into sets of size bounded
from above by some absolute constant
more specifically it would be
interesting to understand the complexity
of the search problem
associated with the combinatorial cycle
plus triangles problem
that was introduced by dussu and wangan
by erdesh and was answered by fleshner
and stubitz
this problem is closely related to the
fair independent certain cycle problem
where the vertex set of the cycle is
partitioned into sets of side 3
and it would be interesting to
understand the computational aspects of
this problem
thank you for your attention
uh great talk i think we should keep the
the questions for the uh
uh poetry panel at the end but um isha
if you can un unshare your your uh
screen then uh
uh next next benjamin can share uh
his screen and if anyone has a very
quick question
okay i hope everyone can hear me um wait
we should all take a deep breath
okay now we're ready for another talk
okay
um so this talk is about um
understanding the relative strength of
qpf cdcl servers
and qpf resolution which was a joint
work with olaf firestore from
the university of vienna in germany so
what we basically wanted to do is we
wanted to analyze
qpf solvers or the power of qbf solvers
in a theoretical way that means we
wanted to somehow find
equivalences or separations between
solvers and underlying proof systems and
somehow
see how they work and why are they so
strong or
weak or whatever okay
so maybe let's start with that solving
itself
well the most i think the most widely
used algorithm in stat solving is the
cdcl algorithm which is just a
conflict-driven clause learning
um and although sub-solving is
known to be np-complete which is pretty
hard problem you could say that these
sat solvers like cdcl
really work very efficiently on let's
say industrial instances
so of course there are also hard
examples for cdcl but most of the
examples
from um from the industry
are pretty pretty well done inside
soldiers
so we could ask the question how strong
are these start always then
can we somehow measure their strength in
a theoretical way or can we
somehow say when such solvers are
hard or when problems for that solvers
are hard on
when they are not
okay and this was basically already done
before and what we did
is we extended this whole problem to the
qbf level so
maybe you know that cdcl can be extra
extended to the qpf level which is then
called qcdcl
that means it can handle quantified
boolean formulas and others
not only propositional formulas
and well the qbf problem is even harder
because it is p space complete
but even there you could say that as in
that solving
here also these qbf servers work pretty
well on these industrial instances
okay so what is ctcl well i won't
explain ctl here i
have explained this dpl in the the long
talk
so cdcl is based on this dpl which is a
little bit more easy
just a little bit easier and um
basically it just adds um
the class learning and non-chronological
backtracking
okay and both algorithms somehow rely on
the proof system resolution which is
pretty well known um and pretty well to
pretty good to analyze um
well one one wrestle we one thing we
did in our work was we wanted to
formalize
at first formalize these cdcl runs
somehow
such that we can analyze them as a proof
system we
did it this way so you could say a cdl
proof looks like the following
consists of three components you could
say
so the first components are these keys
this is just a
sequence of so-called ctcl trails i will
explain in a second what these trailers
are
and then you have these classes c1 to cm
which are just
learned clauses so from each trait you
can learn some clause
because it is called clause learning
and from each learn clause you also get
a sub proof a resolutions are proof
which you can directly extract from this
cdcl run and all in all in combination
this whole cpcl proof really
contains all information you need okay
and what is a trail
well a cdcl trail t is just a sequence
of literals that represents a cdcl
run between two restarts or backtracking
steps
okay so you can think of the following
it's just
a sequence or you could also say an
assignment um
where we have these p literals and these
d literals
so basically these these are our
decision literals
which i have written in bold phase here
and then
we have these p literals which are
propagated literals by unit propagation
which is also
pretty um a pretty important thing in
this algorithm
okay so what do we know about cdcl and
dpll
well that's this correspondence between
um
dpll and three-leg resolution and
even more important there's
correspondence between cdcl and
resolution
so you can extract resolution out of
cdcl runs
and now the question what about the
other direction can we somehow extract
cdcl runs out of the
out of a resolution refutation okay and
then
we have there was a result about 10
years ago
where they basically found out well
cdcl and resolution are p equivalent
which sounds great
but that's one thing you could have to
consider um the cdcl model in this
in this result here contains some
non-deterministic elements that means
some things like decision making really
depends on the refutation
so somehow when you look in the the
algorithm the the code
you have some line like um choose some
non-assigned literal and set it to zero
or one
okay so you have a kind of a freedom
here and
um basically here you have
kind of a non-determinism which you
haven't in the real practice
so in practice ctcl uses uh
fully deterministic procedures for
decision making like
uh for for example decision making or
clause learning
and two years ago we had uh there was
this
result from vinyls where he found out
that
well this deterministic version of cdcl
is really weaker than the resolution
so we have this overview so cdcl
as a partially non-deterministic system
is p equivalent to resolution and
deterministic one is weaker
now what about the quantified level as i
said we want to
make the same discussion in the qpf case
and in qbf you can
extract so-called long-distance key
resolution refutations
out of negative qcd cell runs
okay so you can
from resolution you can go to q
resolution for the qpf case and then you
can even more
extend it to this low so-called long
distance
q resolution i think i will explain it
in the long talk
okay um so here same question
can we gain a similar equivalence as in
such case so can we somehow say that
qc dcl corresponds to q resolution
okay and a rattle from
2016 said that the deterministic or
practical qcd cell
is even weaker than q resolution which
is not very surprising
so question can we at least construct
as in cdcl a partially non-deterministic
qcvcl proof system
which can simulate hue resolution
reputations
and uh well this was our first real
result you could say qcdcl and q
resolution are in fact incomparable
so we have separations in both
directions
so well when what do we do then
well in qbf the picture is a little bit
more complex
than it's at uh as i said
these both systems are incomparable and
um
what we do is we designed a new
qctl model so we changed a few things in
there
and we called this new model qcdcl this
just means a searching order no
reduction
and we prove that this is really
equivalent to
queue resolution okay so basically this
result just states
q resolution and this new uh slightly
changed model is
p equivalent and we get this overview as
you can see here
okay so um
i think my last last slide yeah you can
see this overview here
the dplr corresponds to three-legged
resolution cdcl2 resolution
we have um incomparable systems for qcd
cell and q resolution
and with this new system we have really
a p
equivalence to q resolution
yeah and that's all of it thanks for
listening
and that's a problem okay
so so there will be poems at in the in
the pound discussion after the the talks
let's uh we have two more talks first so
uh
uh thank you benjamin i think it's uh is
peter presenting next
so uh whenever you're ready to share
your slides
excellent maybe if you have like a full
screen mode that might
be better
great
ah okay i'm peter uh this is joint work
with
pavan and vinod um we have a
concept of completeness for
multi-pseudo-determinism
so what we mean by that is
so there's some natural problems
that if we could get a
pseudo-deterministic algorithm
for these problems then we could get
pseudo-deterministic algorithms for
lots of problems so
pseudo-determinism um we're talking
about function problems again here
um a pseudo-deterministic algorithm for
a function problem
consistently outputs the same solution
so here's a little example
this one on the right is
pseudodeterministic because it
outputs a on most random paths
all right so there's been a lot of
recent work
on pseudo-determinism and we know
pseudo-deterministic algorithms for
like finding generators of cyclic groups
non-residues polynomial non-roots
bipartite perfect matchings that
recently got improved to
arbitrary perfect matchings um
and uh prime generation
and it's also been considered in the
context of like interactive proofs and
streaming algorithms
we're going to be talking about
approximation algorithms
where you have some number that you want
to compute
and the acceptable solutions are within
plus or minus epsilon of that number
and it's pretty easy to get an
approximation algorithm narrowed down to
one of
two different values by rounding
to large enough intervals
so this motivated um gold right to
define
multi-suited determinism where instead
of
a single uh canonical solution you have
a canonical set
of some bounded size and
you have an algorithm that lands in that
set with
this pretty good probability
and this specific probability is
actually pretty important because if you
if you have this probability of landing
in the set
you can amplify it by running a
a lot and taking the most common value
if you drop below this value
that no longer works and
we don't know how to do amplification
so
our completeness result
is centered around this
problem of estimating the collision
probability of the circuit
uh what's the chance that you get the
same thing twice in a row
so it's an approximation algorithm so
you can get it to be too
pseudo-deterministic
and that seems to be a hard barrier
going from two to one
because if you could make a
pseudo-deterministic algorithm
then any approximation algorithm you can
make it pseudo-deterministic
um so a quick overview of the proof
um so
we've got an arbitrary approximation
algorithm we'll make it too
pseudo-deterministic
so we've got these two good outputs um
we see either a or b with a combined
probability of three-fourths
we want to eliminate one of them so the
obvious thing to do is to
run a a whole lot and take whichever
value is most likely
that's not going to help if a and b have
roughly equal probability
on the other hand you could try running
the algorithm until you've seen
both a and b and then just using some
arbitrary rule to pick between them like
let's take the bigger one
this is going to have issues if one of
these
you have a very low chance of seeing
so we're going to use our collision
probability estimator to tell us which
of these strategies
to pick and since our collision
probability estimator is pseudo
deterministic
we're going to pick the same strategy on
a particular input every time
and as long as the strategy is okay for
that
input then we'll get a pseudo
deterministic algorithm and we're able
to show that
if you can approximate collision
probability close enough
then it works
we also show uh two other problems to be
complete
estimating the shannon entropy of a
circuit and estimating the
probability that a circuit accepts uh
because
if you can do either of these pseudo
deterministically you can get collision
probabilities pseudo deterministically
we also um wanted to push it beyond just
approximation algorithms
our proof um
extends very nicely to
any multi-valued function
with a small number of outputs
so we talk about multi-valued functions
where you have just an r
the output isn't can be an arbitrary set
of acceptable answers
and we talk about search bpp where
you can generate um solutions with
two-thirds probability
and check solutions in a with like a bpp
algorithm basically
so for multi-value functions we showed
that
you can get any
so any multi-valued function that has
like a constant
pseudo-determinism algorithm you can get
that down to pseudo determinism
assuming this uh collision probability
can be done suited deterministically
and we've actually got that up to a
polynomial
um any algorithm that outputs
a polynomial number of different values
with very high probability
for search bpp we
got something even better if you've got
a pseudo deterministic algorithm
or approximation scheme actually we need
an approximation scheme here
for acceptance probability then you can
make any
search bpp algorithm fully
pseudo-deterministic
so there's a few things to uh
look at from here like what else is
complete
can you do completeness in some of the
other settings that pseudo-determinism
has been considered for
um can you get a complete problem in
search bpp
because approximate
acceptance probability is not in search
bpp because there's no way to check that
you have a good approximation
and can you prove something like
this and uh that's all i've got thank
you for listening
very nice um yeah if you can unshare
your screen and uh alex can share his
and one more talk hang in there
we're uh we're doing great
and great talk so far
can you hear me we can hear you but your
screen disappeared
yeah but yeah okay now everything should
be set up now we have everything wow
okay uh
can i start okay
so yeah i'll present this trying to work
with dorita haranov where we show two
combinatorial may complete problems
so as you see the title the main subject
of our result
is about ma and it is the randomized
version of np and to be more precise
with say that have problems in mma
if there is a polynomial time randomized
algorithm
that is given an instance of the problem
and a proof
and should decide to accept or reject
and you want that for positive instances
there exists a proof
that makes this randomized algorithm
accept with probability one
but for no instances no matter which
proof is given to this randomized
algorithm
it should reject with hyperability
we expect uh m a actually to be
derandomized so we
expect may to be equivalent p and this
is supported by a lot of
widely believable assumptions
but it's still a big open problem in
classical complexity theory
one possible approach to attack this
problem
is for instance to pick an m a complete
problem and show that it is nnp
but a big problem with this approach is
that
even if may was defined in the 80s for a
long time we didn't know
any any complete problem
but then in 2008 bravo in terre haute
they showed that stoquastic low
chromatogram problem is made complete
later on we have seen other um ma
complete problems
but all of them they are defined using
concepts of quantum computing
so the main conceptual question of our
result is
trying to understand if if there is a
fundamental reason for all i may
complete problems to be related with
quantum
or if it's just an accident and we have
other natural
combinatorial and complete problems
so in our result so we define two
problems
so the first one is an extension of
standard
constraints accession problems but to
another setting that we call a set
constraint succession problems or set
csps
the second problem uh that we call acac
it it it is related to finding
clean connected components of implicitly
given graphs
and i'll describe both problems with
more details later
and just to to to finish uh stating our
results
what to show that first um this problem
called set csp is made hard
we show a reduction from set csp to acac
and finally we show that acac is in a
main
so putting all this together we have
that
both acac and set csp rma complete
so now i'll describe a bit more in
details what these problems are and
give some idea of or at least intuition
of the proof
so let's talk first about acac
and here the inputs are is a graph
but the graph is not given explicitly so
we're given a circuit
that on input
on a vertices and here we assume that
the vertices are just
n-bit strings and if on
the circuit only put given an input as
an error
vertex outputs the polynomial in
neighbors rv
and on top of that you have an extra
circuit another circuit
m that on that marks some of these
vertices so
on input v this m output 0 if it's not
marked or 1 if it's marked
and the problem you want to solve is of
deciding if there exists a connector
component
in this implicitly given a graph where
all these vertices in this conductor
component
are not marked or on the other hand
every set of um of vertices
are uh far from being uh
a clean connected component so for these
we need have two
uh constraints so we want that every set
of um
every set of vertices it's either it
either contains a lot of marked elements
or it's far from being a connected
component meaning that it has a lot of
expansion
so we show that acc is in ma and the
verification procedure
is very simple so the prover first gives
one vertex
of this graph and the verifier just
performs a random walk
for polynomial steps on it using using
the implicit description that is given
as input and if at some point the
verifier finds a marked element
the verifier rejects
for completeness it's not hard to see
that
there exists a vertex that the prover
can send that makes the verifier
acceptor explore to one
because there is a clean connector
component so the verifier can just give
any vertex uh on that connector
component and a verifier never rejects
on the other hand for soundness what we
can show that
the properties that you have from
non-instances is that every
set that contains only clean vertices it
expands well
and in this case it means that any
random walk
starting from any vertex should find
them
about a marked element with high
probability
uh let me now switch gears to uh these
setcsp
problems so as i said it is an extension
of csps to to a different setting
so let me just quickly recall what csb
is
so we can think it as having an
assignment and this is just an end bit
boolean string
and we want to this assignment to
satisfy some constraints
and a constraint here you can think just
of a set of substrings on some bits of
this
of this assignment and you want that uh
the the corresponding
uh substring on the on the on the set on
on these bits
uh to be in this set of allowed
substrings
right this is a different way of seeing
set csps
oh sorry set csps and for setcsps we
just
extend this notion of assignment to be
now a set of strings
so we have that uh you want to find a
set of strings that satisfy some
what you call set constraints
the set constraints are also a bit more
complicated than simple
constraints they're not only sets of
strings but these strings
are organized in subsets
so here for instance you have uh the
first two uh
this set constraint is a first subset
that contains two strings zero zero and
one one and a sec
second uh set that contains a single
tone
zero one
and then we for
a set to satisfy a set constraint we
need to have two
two requirements and i'll explain it
about an example that is simpler
so we want that uh first that the
substrings
on each string of the set to be in
one of the sets and this is very similar
with standard ssps you just want that
all the substrings um
of the strings in s should be in descent
but the more important uh uh restriction
here
is that we want that all these strings
that appear together in a set
they should come together in this uh set
uh
like this assignment set so for instance
here
we have that 1 1 0 and 0 0 0
should be all together in this set
constraint
because 0 0 and 1 1 they appear in the
set in the set constraint
and as i said so we were able to show
that
this set csps are made hard and the idea
is that we can
uh the intuition of the proof is that we
use this set s
to contain all the snapshots of ma
computation
and we use the constraints to put all
possible electro to ensure that
all possible random strings are chosen
uh at the beginning and
all all all steps of the computation are
added to this set
just to finish i'd like to give some
perspective so using some
uh the same results of uh hadoven grille
that we had last year
it is not hard to see that if you have a
constant promise gap for set csps
then the problem is in np so we don't
need randomness at all
so this implies that if you have some
sort of set c
a set pcp theorem or a get amplification
for set csp
then it means that you can show that m a
equals np
uh other further questions is showing
that this gap the acac
is also an np or finding other
any complete problems for from our
problems
and thank you for attention
i see there is one raised hand
maybe we can let or ask the question
yeah
so alex you mentioned that set csp with
constant gap is an np
yeah and then one over poly is ma
complete
so what do you think happens in between
like one over polylog
uh okay what i think is that everything
should be in np
right uh i believe that you're an
upgradation contact conjecture
uh but maybe i i mean like do you think
that
that showing that everything it just
comes up to a threshold of one value is
as hard as derandomizing um
so our technique it finds out my rear i
think it's
one of our log log okay we don't prove
this but i think that
you you can push it a little further but
not too big
but but these are just our techniques
but uh
but yeah i don't have other intuition
about the other sets of parameters
okay yeah thanks i think it would be
cool if if there was just one value
of epsilon that if you decide that one
you'd randomized um
okay thanks
so uh thank you for the speakers again
we're now in the uh panel discussion uh
part of the
session um if anyone has any questions
feel free to uh
send raise your hands in a q a q a or
chat or any of those
i also uh asked the speakers um
while you're thinking of questions i
asked the speakers to prepare uh poems
about their papers
so i'll let that while you're thinking
about the
questions i'll let the speakers present
the poems in the order so starting from
uh daniel again then i'll present this
poem
if anyone has questions about any of the
papers uh feel free to interrupt
sure uh so actually bobby wrote this so
credit to him um the time has come
our authors said to talk of many things
of pigeonholes and
shattered sets rigidity and kings and
why some words are far from codes and
gates are input strings
very nice anyone with questions or uh
ishai did you prefer
a poem too
is is shy still in a call
why while you're all still still
thinking about questions i think
benjamin also prepared a poem for us
yeah yeah one second
um okay yeah since um
this whole formalizing um
an algorithm thing pretty much feels
like
taming a wild animal i just called my
poem taming the beast okay so
we planned to tame the beast a beast
called qcdcl
it was done before with its ancestor
that used to be a rebel
having lots of optimism and filled with
determination
we robbed a bit of determinism and
fulfilled the equation
the beast is still out there slowly
losing its margin
it won't give us a nightmare knowing one
day we will win
i don't think i've ever been to an
actual uh poetry session what do people
do between
poems for the increased uh drama
more more clapping uh snapping
okay finger snapping that's more
appropriate
thank you um
who's uh peter do you prepare a poem
uh i took the lazy way out and
just went with a haiku hi cool okay
great
it's basically just the title of the
paper minus a few words
i mean when pseudo deterministic is
seven syllables you don't really have
too much to work with here
fantastic uh alex do you have a boss i
have one
great
so yeah i can put a computer with a
proof and a dice
and problems relatable supplies but if i
see a further cat
just imagine i sweat keep calm we can
prove it twice
okay we can help you twice
i see a raised hand um can we
mute the person raise the hand i missed
it
yep
yep hi uh could you guys uh hear me
yeah we can hear you yep uh thanks i
just
had a quick query in the uh
scalability perspective
with respect to all the panelists so
i would like to ask how do their
algorithms scale in the real
empirical hardware
settings with respect to the
applications
in the cloud
[Music]
well i don't do algorithms so i didn't
algorithm so
benjamin do you have anything you can uh
say about uh solving qbf in practice
yeah could you repeat that
scalability and solving it in practice
um yeah okay
so basically
in practice we really need a
deterministic
model or uh more so if we want to
analyze
practice models we really need
more deterministic models and this one
we had here
are more that
they have too much non-deterministic
elements in there
we can also have uh some sort of uh uh
approximations that can work on that too
with respect to higher dimensional cases
if we
take it there uh or some sort of a
stochastic uh stochasticity
that can be also applied if we extend it
yeah but that will lose its how does it
ah a tight bound but
yeah i think someone i may be
on a tangential uh uh
uh thing here but yeah
so uh what do you guys think about uh
stochasticity and noise and some sort of
upper bound or uh higher dimensions
if you would like to
give your thoughts on that
um if if if no one has any any good uh
insights on this question and another
question that was
uh suggested uh uh specifically in in
the context of uh
the third paper and qbf but what are
good theoretical models for uh
sad slash qbf solving if benjamin or
anyone has
insights of that
yeah okay so i could say good models
would be
models where we really have good
underlying proof systems which we can
analyze so
um for example when we have qcdcl we
know that we can extract these long
distance q resolution proofs but we do
not really know if this is
the perfect way in doing it i mean maybe
there's
there are some other underlying proof
systems that are
somewhere in between so
we really need some sharp
let's say sharp equivalences or sharp
simulations in this so yeah and also
as i said it has to be pretty
much fully deterministic because every
non-determinism in there
is far away from the practice
that's a little bit problem because
deterministic systems are far more
harder to analyze because they're more
chaotic
thank you benjamin there's a question
i'm guessing for alex
um it's an anonymous question in the
q a are the definitions of m a with
accepting probability one and accepting
probability greater than two thirds
four yes instances equivalent yeah yeah
you can you can
yeah you can assume it's one without
loss of generality
so yeah it's an old result i cannot cite
it now who
who proved it but yeah it's it's known
i i had another question alex about uh
what's uh
gapped uh acac oh
uh yeah i didn't get into these details
but
we showed that acic they may complete
for
like we had some parameters epsilon and
then if epsilon is inverse polynomial
then this problem is made hard
may complete and the question is if you
pick this parameter to be
epsilon to be a constant
then what's the complex of this problem
and this and this is just like the
approximation of
of of of this acic how far it is
from being a clean connected component
nice um so so
great um if if anyone has more questions
or or want to uh keep discussing
um uh feel free to to stay on the
zoom call um the the
the other session is is there another
session
oh there's a business meeting that's
starting now and uh i i have to go to a
child care uh session so i'll i'll leave
you but uh
uh thanks again to all the speakers and
especially those who wrote time